[Musik]
okay ist denn die drauf auf dem Server
ein drei kack Kötern da ey ich kacke ab
was will der denn da jetzt von dir
aber wir müssen auch noch den Villager
vorne retten
[Musik]
wo stehe ich denn so so gut mein Fehler
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
wer ist denn da oben bei dir
bei mir
guck mal danach mein Gott Alter ich
mache mir in die Hosen jetzt mal ohne
Witz haben Leute die vor uns schon da
waren die Höhle gebaut
so ich dich mal ganz kurz gegen die
Vitrine werfen
Schwert
ja mit Spitzhacke mist ich habe was
entdeckt eine Person
schwarz und die verliert Blitzer
was meinst du damit welche Person ist
schwarz und verliert Glitzer selber
nachdenken über deinen dummen Fragen
dann mal auf komm Sandra lauf lauf lauf
geht ab unter dem Baum gehen gegen
Enderman kann man quasi nie gewinnen
[Musik]
ach
nein so Idiot ne
[Musik]
mittlerweile reicht's mir ja auch nichts
passiert es reicht doch mittlerweile mit
dem Köter
willst du diesen Stress
[Musik]
jetzt liegen wir wieder die ganzen
Sachen rum wir schaffen wieder nichts
hier heute guck mal unter Wasser
[Musik]
ich werde von irgendwas geschlagen hilf
mir ich kann nicht mit Gott
ist voll mit Lost ich kann nicht in
Worte fassen wie sehr du mich abwachsen
ich werde wieder sterben ich werde
wieder sterben scheiße
ich bin ich bin ich bin tot
einfach ins Bett Luca sondern ich bin
nicht mehr auf unserer Insel bisher
ich will nicht verbrennen ich verbrenne
Alter was
Luca ich Verbrenner ich verbrennen ich
bin gestorben ich bin
nie so oft gestorben
fünfmal gestorben oder so wo sind die
jetzt
junge
schon wieder attackiert das kommen die
ganze Zeit zusammen wieder
[Musik]
ich werde von irgendwas doch geschlagen
Sandra rechts
ich kann nicht mehr
zeigen
[Musik]
die Folge kannst du keinem zeigen das
war wirklich
das ganze wirklich keinem erzählen wir
müssen auch gucken du meintest ja vorhin
es hat geregnet auf dem Server ne
ist halt immer ein bisschen schwierig
kann halt sein dass halt irgendwann zu
so Überschwemmungen oder so kommt
[Applaus]
passiert
wieder lauf weg lauf weg lauf nicht zu
ihm hin
komm nicht runter wie geht man noch mal
die Treppe runter
der Treppe runter
hier einfach runter gehen
bin ich aber
ich komme da nicht runter
wie setze ich ein Pferd ein Ding auf
hast du Sattel
oh ich habe es getötet scheiße
ich habe einen Sattel für dich
kann man dem Pferd Pferdefleisch geben
du bist so ein
auf Rechtsklick und dann zähmen
hey macht Sandra das richtig ich habe
noch nie ein Pferd gezähmt glaube ich in
minecraft nein du darfst nicht in der
Hand halten mach mal den Sattel Weg
Sandra eine Ewigkeit später okay Sattel
ist drauf und jetzt kannst du reiten
glaube ich so schnell wir sind so
schnell
ist die denn
das einmal das Pferd reiten
[Musik]
wie ist es so sei ehrlich
ein Rock
seht ihr wenn ich daran gehe sicher auf
einmal die Polen Flagge
[Musik]
als ich gerade die das Ding geöffnet
habe kam mir so drei Polen Flaggen
entgegen
ja hey Scheiße mein Arschloch
[Musik]
ich habe eine Katze
was ich habe
nein hast du mein Pferd erlebt du hast
ohne Grund meine Katze getötet jetzt ist
alles unsere ganze Grundlage für den
vorhin geplante Tierfarm ist weg ich
reicht komplett aus ich habe den Sattel
zugeworfen den kannst du nehmen für dein
nächstes fährt dann kannst du ein neues
Pferd oder nur ich mir eine neue Katze
aber dann sind wir quitt okay
[Musik]
warum ich habe doch einen rohen Lachs
komm her Muschi
hä
was tue ich denn du brauchst Kabeljau
nee oder
ey wenn ich so wählerisch sind Katzen
guck mal das sagt schon wieder alles
warum ich Runde normal mag ich gehe hier
raus Minecraft mit Sandra Minecraft
loser ist an der Stelle beendet
[Musik]